Washington wants to control more and
more of our lives but they can't even
fix their own escalators for decades DC
subway escalators have provided a
uniquely unwelcoming reception to
visitors of our nation's capitol they've
caused cuts pileups broken arms
electrocution heart attacks and even
death almost a quarter million people
showed up for the Jon Stewart and
Stephen Colbert rally back in 2010
heading home some demonstrators
experienced a different sort of Horror
Show when the brakes stopped working on
this escalator which landed four
passengers in the hospital these days
one out of eight escalators is out of
service at all times we are in the
elevator because the escalator is broken
this is the only alternative people have
they're literally trapped is this
disappointing yes
escalators are broken was that okay
broken broken Metro says its mechanics
are working around the clock but on a
weekday afternoon every repair site we
could find was abandoned broken
escalators your thoughts really
irritating especially when you're
wearing heels in the morning and
Russians were broken escalators big
problem right it's a terrible problem
this is horrible it's frustrating isn't
it did it ruin your commute it really
does well just no ma'am
we're on it the problem stems partly
from a decision that was made 20 years
ago and 1992 Metro got rid of the
private contractors that repaired and
maintained the system and started hiring
and training its own escalator mechanics
the rationale was that government
employees would do a better job for less
money I've seen people that were
supposed to be working on an escalator
sleeping on the job they weren't well
trained they didn't like working there
robert begi has been repairing and
inspecting escalators for 47 years and
he worked for Metro in the mid 90s begi
says Metro has been a magnet for
escalator mechanics who can't cut it in
the private sector the quality of the
people we had there was very poor I
thought for an example comb plait you
break two teeth on it you have to shut
the unit off because it's a tripping
hazard
or you can catch a foot instead of just
taking four screws out putting a new
piece in they look at it say well I
don't have the parts they go away for a
couple of hours come back and that would
turn into a four hour job used to drive
me crazy begi resigned from metro in
1998 when he was asked to falsify safety
records they were putting people in
jeopardy saying repairs and maintenance
were done to the escalators that was it
two years ago Metro hired an outside
consultant to study its escalator
problems the report found many machine
rooms were flooded with water and
stuffed with trash while the equipment
was covered in dirt and lacking in
lubricant listen to the units they're
making noise or rattling it's least to
me it's obvious what's wrong with the
escalator gear units are dry chains need
to be oiled handrails are running at a
different speed than the steps which is
critical until Metro which ignored our
request for an interview finds a way to
introduce in competition the nation's
top bureaucrats will have to walk not
ride when trying to get to where they're
going in the most powerful city in the
world